welcome back and i want to introduce you
really just a different notation for
writing vectors and then we'll do that
same problem or a slight variation on
that problem uh using the new notation
and this is just to expose you to things
and so that you don't get confused if
your teacher uses a different notation
than what i've been doing so when we did
the unit vectors we learned that we can
express a vector as this as a component
of its x and y component so let's say i
had a vector let's say in the last
problem i had the vector
i had the vector what was the vector
well let me just pick a random vector
just to show you so say i have vector a
and that equals i don't know 2
times the unit vector i
plus 3 times the unit vector j
that's the unit vector notation i
actually looked it up on wikipedia and
they actually call that the engineering
notation and that's probably why i use
it because i am an engineer or i was an
engineer before managing money
but another way to write this and i call
this the bracket notation or the
ordered pair notation is you could also
write it like this
you have just one bracket
that's the
x component
and that's the y component it almost
looks like a coordinate pair but since
they have the brackets you know it's a
vector but you would draw it the exact
same way
so given that let's do that same problem
that we had just done hopefully this
makes sense to you you know it's just a
different way of writing instead of an i
and a j you just write these brackets
instead of a plus you add a comma okay
let's clear this
and i'm going to do a slight variation
this was actually the second part of
that problem my cousin gave these
problems to me they're pretty good so i
figure to stick with them
so in the old problem let me draw my
coordinate axes
again
so
y-axis
that's the x-axis
so in the old problem i started off
with a ball that was four feet off the
ground so let's say that's four
and i hit it
at 120 feet per second
at a 30 degree angle
so it's a 30 degree angle like that
it's a 30 degree angle to the horizontal
and there's a fence 350 feet away
that's 30 feet high so the fence is 30
feet high so it's roughly right in there
that's 30.
and what we need to do is figure out
whether the ball can clear the fence and
we figured out in the last time when we
used the unit vector notation that it
doesn't clear the fence but in this in
this problem or the second part of this
problem they say that there's a five
meter per second wind gust to the right
so
there's a wind gust of five meters per
second
right when i hit the ball and you could
go into the complications of how much
does that accelerate the ball or what's
the air resistance of the ball i think
for the simplicity of the problem
they're just saying that the x component
of the ball's velocity right after you
hit it increases by five meters per
second
i think that's their point so let's go
back and do the problem the exact same
way that we did the last time but we'll
use a different notation
so we can write that equation that i had
written before that the position at any
given time
the position at any given time as a
function of t
is equal to the initial position
that's a i right there
plus
the initial
velocity
these are all vectors
the initial
velocity
times t
plus
the acceleration vector
over 2 t squared
so what's the initial position and now
we're going to use some of our new
notation
the initial position
when i hit the ball
it's x
component is zero right
it's almost it's like its coordinate and
and they're not that different of a
notation
and then the y position is four
easy enough
what's its initial velocity
let me do it
so we can split up into the x and the y
components
the y component is
120 sine of 30 degrees
and then the x component is 120 cosine
of 30 degrees
and then they also tell us so that's
just just the x component after i hit it
but then they say there's this wind gust
so it's going to be plus five i think
that's their point when they say that
there's this wind gust they say that
right when you hit it for some reason in
the x direction it accelerates a little
bit
by five meters per second
so what was
so the
velocity vector this notation actually
is better because it takes less space up
and you have all these i's and j's and
pluses confusing everything so the
initial velocity vector what's its x
component it's 120 cosine of 30 cosine
of 30 is square root of 3 over 2
times 120 is
60 square roots of 3 and then you add 5
to it so what is that let me just
solve it right now
so 3
times the square root square root of 3
times
60
is equal to and then let's add five
plus five
so let's just round up make it easy it's
109 meters per second 108.9 so let's
just say 109.
so the x component of the velocity is
109
and the y component was just 120 times
the sine of 30. well this is sine of 30
is a half so this is 60.
oh sorry
this should be brackets although some
people actually write the parentheses
there so it looks just like coordinates
but i like to keep it with these
brackets so that you don't think that
these are coordinates you know these are
vectors
and the position vector really is the
same thing as a position coordinate but
a velocity vector is
obviously not a coordinate and then
what's the acceleration vector well the
acceleration vector as we said go
straight that's not straight down this
is straight down it
says minus 32
feet per second squared that's the
acceleration of gravity on earth so the
acceleration vector
is equal to it has
no x component
and its y component is minus 32.
so now let's put these back in that
original equation so our position vector
and i will switch colors to keep things
from getting monotonous
our position vector
these are little arrows or one-sided
arrows but
equals
my initial position and that's 0
4
plus my initial velocity
vector
109
60
times t
and i'm running out of space
plus
a t squared over 2. so t squared over 2
plus
t squared over 2
times my acceleration vector
0
minus 32. and it should be
this is actually a little cleaner way of
writing it but this is exactly what we
did when we did it with unit vectors
instead of writing the i's and js we're
just writing the numbers in brackets
here
so let's see if we can simplify this so
let me let me draw a line let me write a
different color so that you know what
i'm doing
okay so our position vector
t is equal to
let's write that 0 4
plus
and now we can distribute this t
multiply it times both of these
plus
109
t
60t
plus
and we can distribute this t squared
over two well that times zero is zero
and then that times minus 32 is
minus
16 t squared
and now we can add the vectors
so the position at any
t
so let's add all the x components of the
vector 0 109 t 0. so
we just get 109
t
and then what's the y components
four
plus
60 t
minus 16 t squared
minus 16
t squared
and there we go and we've defined the
position vector at a function of any
time so let's solve the problem now that
they had this wind gust and our x
velocity is going a little faster let's
see if we can clear the fence so how
long does it take to get to 350 feet in
the x direction
well this number right here has to equal
350. so we have 109
t has to be equal to 350.
and so what's 350 divided by 109 350
divided by
0 9 is equal to
3.2 seconds
t is equal to 3.2
seconds and so what's the height at 3.2
seconds
so let's square that so let me
3.2 times 3.2
equals
times 16 equals 163
point let's just say 164 so this equals
164
and then what's 60 times 3.2
60
times 3.2 is equal to 192.
92. so what do we get
we get 192.
sorry we have 192 plus 4
plus
4
minus 164 right
minus
164
is equal to 32
so
our position vector
at time 3.2 seconds
is equal to
350 feet in the x direction
and
32
32
feet in the y direction
and that will clear that 30
that 30 foot fence our ball is going to
be two feet above the fence
hope i didn't confuse you too much see
you soon